How did a concert film shatter box office
records?
Here's the truth behind the deal Taylor Swift
made with AMC, and how it's paying out beaucoup
bucks for the pop star.
"Taylor Swift: The Eras Tour" made a reported
$92 million domestically in its opening weekend.
At the time of this video, the movie's total
worldwide box office earning is more than
$178 million and still climbing.
That is a tremendous amount of money for a
documentary, which is the film genre the concert
movie technically falls into.
According to Out Magazine, the film broke
AMC's record for first-day pre-sales, grossing
$26 million in its first 24 hours of being
on sale, outperforming the previous record-breaker,
"Spider-Man: No Way Home."
Now, since it's been out, it's already become
the highest grossing concert movie of all time.
The previous king was Justin Bieber, whose
"Never Say Never" grossed over $99 million
at the global box office.
This also makes "The Eras Tour" the first
concert movie to make more than $100 million.
Why was it such a big hit?
Well, let's start with the obvious stuff.
Taylor Swift is more popular than ever before
in her 17-year career.
"I'm a Swiftie."
This certainly fueled the sensation that is
The Eras Tour, and the fervor for this tour
has only made Swift's spotlight shine brighter.
Swift has cemented herself as the biggest
act in pop music at this point in time.
The tour showed just how large and diverse
Taylor Swift's fanbase is to sell as many
tickets as it has for the prices they've gone
for.
Her astronomical rise has even been on the
minds of many culture writers; The Guardian
credits Swift's current ubiquity partly to
the new pop music economy where radio play
matters less than cult-like followings discussing
their favorite artist's every move on Reddit
and TikTok.
No matter the reason, the success of The Eras
Tour — both the tour and the concert movie
— happened because Swift has such an enduring
base of fans.
This is the biggest factor in the success
of "The Eras Tour" film.
Leftover demand from the North American leg
of the tour is insatiable; Taylor Swift found
a way to let even more money pour in while
giving fans a second chance to see the show
if they couldn't make it IRL.
"I didn't get to go to the tour, so I'm excited
to see it on the big screen."
Of course, it took a sizable investment to
make the movie — $10 to $20 million according
to Puck — but that has more than paid off
for Swift now that the film has taken control
of the box office.
The tickets for The Eras Tour were so scarce
and the resale prices were so high that it
nearly broke the Internet.
Even though this is Taylor Swift we're talking
about, we have to take into account the history
of the genre when talking about expectations.
While concert films occasionally turn out
to be cinematic masterpieces like "Gimme Shelter"
or "Stop Making Sense," these aren't always
the biggest money makers in a given year.
Again, the highest-grossing concert movie
until now was Justin Bieber's "Never Say Never,"
which didn't crack $100 million.
In a film landscape dominated by big studios
and streaming platforms, it's been quite a
while since a concert movie has felt like
an event.
Comparing this to the year's biggest movies
— for instance, "Barbie" made almost $1.5
billion — Swift's box office takeaway might
not seem like much.
It's worth noting, though, that the budget
for a concert documentary is often 10 times
lower than that of a Hollywood production.
Reportedly, the budget for "The Eras Tour"
was $20 million.
Compare that to, say, the $200 million budget
for "Killers of the Flower Moon."
"Taylor Swift: The Eras Tour" came to theaters
on October 13, 2023 — a week with no other
major new movies.
All the biggest movies at the box office the
week "The Eras Tour" came out were released
the week before.
The movie that wound up being its biggest
competition, "The Exorcist: Believer," even
got out of the way in anticipation of Swift's
dominance.
Blumhouse founder Jason Blum tweeted the decision,
saying:
"Look what you made me do.
The Exorcist: Believer moves to 10/6/23. #TaylorWins."
Even though it came out a week before "The
Eras Tour," "The Exorcist: Believer" struggled
anyway, making $26 million in its opening
weekend.
Word of mouth on that specific sequel was
pretty sour, but even with a better critical
response, an R-rated horror movie was never
going to compete with the marketing force
that is Taylor Swift.
Outselling "Killers of the Flower Moon" in
the concert film's second week in theaters
is a much more impressive feat.
Yes, "Killers" is a three-and-a-half-hour
R-rated drama, but it's from "Goodfellas"
and "The Departed" director Martin Scorsese
and features the considerable star power of
Robert De Niro and Leonardo DiCaprio.
"This wealth should come to us."
Yet, despite the mostly glowing reviews, "Killers
of the Flower Moon" could not compete with "The Eras Tour."
In a normal world, tickets to The Eras Tour
would have been affordable for every family
to bring their kids if they wanted to.
Still, even if you could afford tickets, other
factors got in the way: It's harder to travel
with children, and kids have a harder time
staying up late for a long concert.
Eras Tour setlists were routinely over three
hours long.
But if your kid falls asleep in the middle
of a three-hour movie, well, it's not as big of a deal.
Plus, it's a lot easier to get everyone together
and file out of a movie theater than it is
a sold-out stadium.
In the time it would take you to get to the
concert stadium parking lot, you can make
the drive home from the movie theater — or
stick around and watch it again.
"I'm gonna go to this movie at least 13 times."
Young people are a large part of Taylor Swift's
demographic and the fans who were too young
to go to the show can see the movie with their
parents.
Immediately, that makes for a bunch of tickets
sold, as evidenced by the pre-sale numbers
that "The Eras Tour" movie put up.
There's a strong argument for the IMAX potential
of "Taylor Swift: The Eras Tour."
The appeal is obvious.
You are already going to the movie not for
a narrative, but for the immersive experience
you can only get from being in a movie theater.
IMAX's strengths enhance the audiovisual experience
of movies with an emphasis on spectacle.
"The Eras Tour" is all spectacle and a natural
fit for the format.
On opening weekend, the film was shown on
625 IMAX screens in 45 markets around the
world and IMAX sales accounted for a double-digit
percentage of the opening weekend pre-sales.
That is a pretty massive percentage for a
format most movies don't even get released in.
More screens mean more IMAX tickets sold,
and of course, theaters charge more for IMAX
tickets, which factors into the box office
success of "The Eras Tour."
One of the reasons "The Eras Tour" film got
made was that Taylor Swift took it on as a personal project.
According to Puck, Swift and her family put
up the reported $20 million that it cost to
fund the project.
It's not a surprise that they would be able
to make this happen, given how much money
they have made on The Eras Tour alone.
According to Fortune, the tour is set to be
the first to ever shatter $1 billion made
in ticket sales — that's not even including
the $75 hoodies and $45 t-shirts.
When you're the biggest pop star in the world,
it turns out you don't need something as silly
as a movie studio to make something happen.
"It's not not true."
When it comes to the current competition,
we've established that "The Eras Tour" is
blowing everyone out of the water.
But let's put that success in comparison to
some of the biggest movies of the year.
"Barbie" is the biggest hit of the year, grossing
over $1.4 billion at the worldwide box office.
Its competitor-slash-companion "Oppenheimer"
fell just shy of $1 billion.
"The Eras Tour" was never going to hit the
heights of these giants, nor that of "The
Super Mario Bros. Movie," which grossed a
mighty $1.36 billion.
If we look closer to where "The Eras Tour"
lands on the list, it seems sure to slip into
the top 20 for the year.
At $178 million in the first two weeks of
release, "Eras" is looking to overtake "Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles: Mutant Mayhem," "The
Equalizer 3," and "Insidious: The Red Door"
with another weekend of strong sales.
The way the deal between Taylor Swift and
AMC Theaters shook out is another potential
reason for its runaway success.
AMC agreed to a contract with Swift that earned
her 57% of the earnings on the film and left
AMC the rest.
According to Variety, this is a smaller cut
than many major studios take — Marvel is
cited as an example of a studio that receives
closer to 65% of the box office profits.
Getting an advantageous deal could be quite
a boon for AMC as it turns out the company
has a hit on its hands.
"They announced Taylor Swift's movie broke
the record for the most pre-sale tickets sold
in one single day, and their CEO is predicting
this will be very lucrative for the company."
According to MarketWatch, shares of AMC have
fallen 73.3% in 2023, although the comparatively
successful summer haul of "Barbie" and "Oppenheimer"
created some cause for optimism.
Taylor Swift's concert movie lighting up the
box office may just continue the upward trend
for the movie theater company.
There are a couple of key things to glean
from the box office success of Taylor Swift's "The Eras Tour."
For starters, Swift's partnership with AMC
sets a precedent for concert films going forward
— one that has already been followed up
by the other biggest female pop act in the world.
Beyonce's upcoming ambitious concert film
"Renaissance" is going to be distributed through
AMC Theaters in a similar fashion.
According to Variety, Beyonce negotiated directly
with AMC for the release of the filmed version
of her Renaissance World Tour.
"Did the girls of summer save the US economy?"
This doesn't just feel like the way of the
future for concert movies — a genre that
has been increasingly relegated to streaming
platforms as the years go on.
In the wake of recent labor tumult in the
land of Hollywood, AMC is opening the possibility
of working directly with filmmakers and creatives
without the need for a studio to act as a distributor.